what's your hinge um what's the line
what's your line what's my screen name
like what's your no what's your like
line I have a gun is it no that's
actually a really good
one so what is a um something that
bothers you that girls put in their
dating profile I'll tell you love this
it's a lot of the same and I don't think
I have a great profile I don't think
girls know that they're doing it the
same I don't think guys do either so
like on this on the Ria dating app you
can add a song and when I tell you 20%
of the guys put mbot by Hansen because
they think it's like funny it's like a
stupid song like or little put a joke
song and it's like I know you think this
is funny but most guys do it what's the
thing girls are doing like that it's a
lot of the it's literally not an
influencer get out I need an influencer
I'm kidding no flag but it'll be it's
like the same thing as like just need
somebody to get spicy margaritas with
looking for the best espresso Martini in
town or it'll be like what what's your
age you need to go younger it's sounds
like you're dating women in their 40s
Ros all day no all no all these hand is
filled with alcoholics every girl on
there is like just the place to drink
apparo Spritz just the place to get me
out of my HR job he he alcohol it's like
what about a book whoa they're like you
don't need to roofy me I'll pass myself
out that's what I write no I don't write
that but it's a lot of like um it it's
like uh one of the prompts is like I
will fall in love for you and then they
write if you trip me and I'm like what
are we doing on a tight five here oh
gosh it's like that it's it's a lot of
it's a like it's either that or it's
like the most rational fear like men
which like yeah I get there's a lot of
guys out there but as a guy how what am
I supposed to like heart that be like
hey these guys suck right I um want to
know about these dates you're going on
what are women doing wrong on dates with
you I don't think it's what are women
doing wrong I think I just
like I think my
cuz I have a theory I think you need to
date a little older yeah for a bit okay
when I hear younger guys complain I'm
like they're like and then she makes me
take photos of her and then I had to pay
and I spent all this money and she lives
with nine roommates and she's de and I'm
just over here like in my fully paid for
H I'm like I may have a couple lines on
my face but like yeah yeah I I I I just
you know what I want I want a girl who
loves her job I don't because I love
what I do so much great one that's a
great one so I like kind of look for
that if they're talking about work and
I'm like yeah oh that's that's that's if
someone doesn't like their job they're
always going to be miserable and you
have to hear about it it's just I don't
care what your job is as long as you
love it well you also feel bad for
liking your job if I come back how are
the shows so great so fun just did this
city it was awesome I got a premiere on
Tuesday I got this and that and then
you're like oh oh how how was work oh
was terrible you're
like I'm just over here loving my job I
might be a little older I love my job
I've got athletic greens and a glass
canister I've Got Hand Soap and every
bathroom my paid off I'm going to
therapy weekly not even
bi-weekly I have a bowl of limes
downstairs real real limes damn and I
know what to do with them I don't I just
get the fake foam ones and bu into cards
in every room I don't even know why you
really this is what happened yeah I got
cards everywhere I got the real Anthony
fouchy I got a I got every fouchy
writing books now get that guy in a la
have you ever dated someone older uh
I've been on dates with women who are
older but not like dated how was it
different it does seem a little more
like is this a thing or not Mama's got a
shot clock it does seem a little more
like we there's no room for games but I
like that interesting it's like I I need
a middle ground cuz like a 25 be like he
he play games I'll text you in 4 days
I'm like what do you mean uhhuh you're
going to snap streak yeah four days see
you know everything I'm very young young
gravy just little teen mom here yes what
a show that was 16 and Pregnant what was
it Teen Mom all those wild but 20 so
like 25y olds play too many games
because it's like I want to I'm hot I
need to have some mystery I get that
right but you also you bite when you
blow give blowjobs I can I already tell
yeah of course you use your teeth you
still haven't figured that out what's
all this are they like on Snapchat
sucking you off you're like we making
money on this use The Flash come
on um or I mean if they're like you know
a little older than me then it it feels
very much like there was a big
relationship before you oh and now you
don't know how soon after also like
hinge feels like an emergency room where
everybody's just like injured and you're
like who's who needs to be seen first
yeah yeah and there's like a 39-year-old
who's like I've been through all of it
and I don't even have health insurance
and then there's like a 25-year-old
who's like I just got a little cut but
I'm okay but that cut is deep cut is
deep and then I'm in there just
delusional and she got the cut from a
Tik Tok challenge that went horribly
wrong yes or next she's in there because
she ate a tide pod but it just feels
like you're in a room where everybody's
coming from a story you know and you
don't know what that story is and a lot
of times it's just normal they weren't
dating or they dated a few relationships
but like you interesting about Hing is
it tells you it'll be like how new they
are it'll be like new here it's like oh
so you're just fresh out of a
relationship yes nobody's just like
sitting around for eight months like oh
I could use a dating app what is this I
definitely go back on the dating app
after something's over yeah but like I'm
definitely like someone distract me so
that's the worst energy to go into it
with exactly and also they haven't
healed from that previous relationship
so they're still I haven't healed from
six relationships ago